sanders said that the browns made some
adjustments after half time um i think
he said their
their linebackers started coming a
little bit more downhill when you looked
at the film
what did you see from the cleveland
defense in the second half
their linebackers coming downhill
he's out there competing in his heart
out and then
you know guys are supposed to go into
press conferences and parse their words
like bill clinton
you know uh that's really not i don't
that's not what guys do you know guys
are athletes they're trying to compete
and play and then
everything they say gets gets minced so
i don't take it too seriously
that's kind of medium
that was john harbaugh under that mask
and uh that's the setup for this week's
airing of grievances
we spoke way too long in the first two
segments even though we didn't think we
were going to so there isn't a lot of
time for grievances today chris do you
have one
oh i do i mean i got two really but i
mean the first one you heard me
i want to talk about this because this
happened last week all right and this is
my issue
you heard about jc jackson right the
patriots not submitting his name
to the pro bowl ballot hey come on
that's bs you know
first off these are the the little bull
crap political games that go on in
football
all over the place jc jackson getting to
the point where he needs a new contract
he's one of the better corners in
football
the patriots have been playing the game
of not starting him
in a number of games this year you know
and for my belief
because he's in the very next series the
first play back it's you know
starting corner my belief there is
because they're going to use it as a
negotiating tie
it doesn't even start for us yeah yes he
covers the second best receiver on the
team every week but he doesn't start for
us
you know and then the pro bowl thing to
add it to that you know that that's just
that's
you're messing with people's lives
careers everything that way
that pissed me off i felt bad for jc
jackson who had some rough issues in
college
and was you know way down the line
as far as the draft he was undrafted
right i can't even remember
now but here he has a chance to make
some money and they're going to finagle
things and i i didn't like that
chris it reminds me of the still
lingering mystery about
why malcolm butler didn't play in super
bowl 52
his final game with the patriots he
refused all offers the patriots had made
on a new contract he ultimately signed
with the titans
and there are people who are convinced
the patriots win that game if malcolm
butler plays defense that day
yeah i mean probably there's no doubt i
mean i don't i have a hard time thinking
the snowball effect of that
okay and here's my other one defenses
they gotta start letting defenses play
all right i'm sick of this jalen ramsey
got called for pass interference the
other night on two plays
where it was offensive past interference
i mean i saw it as offensive pass
appearance
they call jamel dean for lowering the
head the wide receiver carrying the ball
lowered his head and hurt jamal dean and
then they picked the flag up because
they originally called on jamal dean how
about call it on the offense they're
making it too hard on the defense i'm
sorry it's driving me crazy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports